cette semaine je vous conseille de venir
au grenier à sel pour découvrir khroma
nous connaissaient shaun le mouton vous
connaissez ou à la synchro mythe vous
connaissez chicken run voici leurs
ancêtres le studio britannique arman
propose des films drôles et originaux
avec de l'animation en pâte à modeler ça
c'est assez original dont image par
image
on va suivre les personnages qui vont
prendre vie sur le grand écran et
l'adanc romane le clan de doom notre
héros va affronter un clan qui est passé
à l'âge de qui lui est passé à l'âge de
bronze
il fonce à compter sur un terrain de
foot le fait marrer c'est dur 1h29 nous
conseillons à partir de 6 ans mais il
plaira aussi aux adultes et c'est
pourquoi j'aime aussi me une séance à
20h45 le vendredi 2 mars
vous retrouvez nos films des horaires
sur notre site internet cinéma grenier à
sel points comme je vous dis à bientôt
[Musique]